[Música]
boa noite internet boa noite tarde x
blumenau
antes de começar o que eu pedi pro
pessoal das câmeras por favor podem
formar turmas não filme as minhas mãos
aqui que como atleta falou a geringonça
todos estão vendo esse roteiro na mão eu
tenho esse privilégio não privilegiar
dinho então vou ter na mão é porque vou
fazer aqui ao vivo 11 um episódio não
pode caixa é o brinquedo que a gravação
do cd ao vivo é ea quem ouve podcast
levanta a mão quem o podcast aí muito
bem vocês fazem um ano do podcast do
brasil e número pode cair se eu explico
o mundo através de histórias
interessantes mas normalmente é feito
num estúdio eu sento não sei mais ou
menos parecido com esse
falo e depois a minha editora corta os
meus erros botamos e quente fundo tudo
muito calmo muito sereno que não vai ser
o caso aqui então é por isso que ninguém
pode filmar minhas mãos mas lá que eu
vou fazer um truque de mágica ou nada
porque ela não tá tremendo pra caramba
então vai distrair vocês não vou prestar
atenção no que eu tô falando nós vamos
lá vai dar tudo certo tudo sob controle
aí vai ser legal pra caramba boa noite
internet no brasil eu sou crise dias
teve essa mega sena gigante agora e
sempre que rolam esses super prêmios até
acumulou de novo você deve passar um
tempo pensando no que faria da vida com
100 milhões do banco uma vida sem dar
satisfação para ninguém
aliás dizem que essa é a melhor maneira
de descobrir o que você realmente gosta
de fazer na vida pensar no que é que
você faria se não precisasse ganhar
dinheiro
bom se eu tivesse tanto dinheiro que eu
não precisasse maggi me preocupar com
dinheiro eu ia passar o tempo todo com
as coisas que importam para mim que dão
sentido para a vida e valor porque a
gente faz
vocês acham que eu falo da minha família
não estou falando de videogame galera
eu adoro jogar videogame eu eu gosto
mais de jogar videogame que eu deveria
reconhecer que eu gosto e isso acontece
porque videogame transporta para um
mundo diferente onde eu não preciso ser
eu a maior parte do tempo eu gosto de
ser quem eu sou mas tem uns o 24 horas
por dia nem eu me aguento
e já que eu não consigo ser jogador
profissional de videogame que eu sou
muito ruim jogando então eu fico aqui e
só pensando no impacto que os jogos têm
na nossa vida esse tipo de coisa por
exemplo de umas décadas para cá os
videogames ficaram muito populares são
tão parte da cultura quanto filmes ou
séries de tv
isso fez com que os jogos campeões de
venda de se vender milhões ficar sem
passeios demais morrer no jogo virou só
um inconveniente
antes quando você morria tinha que
começar tudo de novo do zero e às vezes
você não era nem você que morrerá a sua
mãe que desligava o jogo da tomada e
você perdia tudo que tinha conquistado
isso é falta de caráter já hoje tem um
jogo de ação que se você levar muito
tiro é só ficar parados corrigindo canto
que a sua barra de vida volta tipo
wolverine
parece então que os jogos não querem
magoar quem está jogando
o designer de jogos então concordaram
comigo de uns tempos pra cá começaram a
lançar jogos que ficaram famosos por
serem muito difícil e não perdoar quando
o jogador erra
são jogos tipo a série dark souls mas
também jogos aparentemente fofinhos como
campeã red ou celeste que é um jogo de
plataforma com visual tipo o mário do
nintendinho
e essa nova abordagem deu super certo o
público adorou mudança na brincadeira já
a reclamação foi gigante a galera falou
que jogo é coisa pra relaxar para
distraí que difícil e pensa já tem outra
coisa sabe que a vida porque a vida não
tem seletor de dificuldade não tem um
botãozinho opção no menu pois não como
você gostaria que fosse a sua vida fácil
ou beleza
então o que é que eu posso aprender com
videogame para deixar o jogo da vida
aqui menos tenso
uau eu vou contra a ideia de que os
jogadores estão sendo mimados
é eu acho que são quem dizem que passam
sensações muito diferentes
é o que eu falo sempre durante a tarde
um jogo que você compra com a certeza
absoluta de que você vai chegar à final
começou pode quer ser o jeito que eu
respondo perguntas e sair por aí
entendendo o mundo e depois dividir o
que eu aprendi com vocês aqui no meu
podcast
por isso eu fui conversar com esses
caras vocês ouviram o danilo silvestre o
adriano brandão de outro podcast o pouco
pixel que fala sobre videogames
especialmente de jogos antigos porque se
eu preciso de alguém para me ajudar a
entender por que eu gosto tanto de
videogame
o que eu posso levar ele pra minha vida
aqui fora a opção esses dois caras
a gente escolhe jogos porque eles são
desafios controlados que a gente sabe
que tem solução
a gente não pode pensar nos jogos como
se a gente tivesse simplesmente se
aceitando o desafio pizarro difícil e
sofrido
a gente sabe que ele é resolvível é que
nem sempre esperando antigamente se você
tiver o número de fichas você termina o
jogo
a criança quando ela faz desafios para
ela própria
ela não faz desafios que ela não possa
dar conta já falei vou tentar subir
naquele mar e ela vai tentar subir ela
consegue subir vai falar eu vou voar até
à lua
quem estuda a mente humana que não é meu
caso só escrevo sobre quem estuda as
coisas sérias
essa galera especialista fala que um dos
ingredientes da felicidade na vida em
geral é você sentir que tem controle
sobre a sua vida é meio saber que no fim
tudo vai dar certo que nem essa gravação
e é isso que o jogo dá a certeza de que
no final tudo vai dar certo muito mais
que um filme uma série onde você não tem
controle nenhum você só um espectador
passivo até o contrário é o filme tem
uma sensação de controle absoluta porque
não depende de mim é totalmente nada
possa dormir durante o filme que ele vai
chegar no ponto que o crime deveria
chegar o jogo tá no meu inconsciente que
é controlado mas ele me dá uma falsa
ilusão de descontrole eu acho que eu vou
poder morrer eu acho que posso perder
aquela final da copa do mundo da fifa é
uma insegurança que eu quero porque eu
estou buscando assim
frança porque lá no fundo do meu cérebro
dito assim mas é só um jogo e se não for
assim não tem problema pode ser assim
o filme - frustrante porque o filme
acontece tudo certo o jogo eu quero às
vezes me senti frustrado não é selecao
uneb vida onde toda vez que eu tentasse
fazer uma coisa eu posso ir lá e
conseguir não sei o que pensa se fosse
assim um videogame cheguei no chefão lá
e clown eu votei na primeira tentativa
de ser o que é um jogo mais chato do
mundo um jogo bom é que a gente aprende
com os nossos erros
um jogo independente eu gosto muito que
é o play e upgrade é todo baseado num
conceito filosófico que é se eu cometi
um erro
eu aprendo com esse erro imediatamente
eu sei que deu errado eu preciso além do
aprendizado ser punido por ele
se você cai num buraco que você não
deveria imóvel já fugiu de aprender o
que precisa ser punido e tem que começar
tudo de novo e aí ele funciona com o
sistema de rebobina e cinco segundos faz
de novo
é a gente a acabou associando na
história dos videogames dificuldade como
punição eu acho que a gente faz isso na
vida também
às vezes a gente acha que pra uma coisa
valeu a pena pra aparecer quem foi
melhor na prática a gente aprendeu a
gente tem que ser punido a gente tem que
ter sofrido o brilho de um jogo que
mostra que a coisa pode ter valor você
tem orgulho do que você fez sem que a
punição tenha acontecido
[Música]
tá bom então é isso a gente joga pra
aprender a ser resiliente seguir
tentando até conseguir
eu achei que tinha mais para descobrir
fui direto na fonte
eu fui conversar com uma pessoa que tem
como profissão tomar essas decisões de
como é um jogo ou ele dá mole eu sou e
crack e 20 onde o meu trabalho é definir
a atual regra de jogo porque ninguém
aqui vai conter mecânica dinâmica de
qualquer disso o felipe aqueles ficou em
porto alegre e é hoje um dos maiores
estúdios de games do brasil com uma
equipe de mais de 80 pessoas fazendo
jogos para o mundo todo
um desses jogos é um raio x que é um
jogo de carro homenageando aqueles jogos
antigos tipo pop gay out lã onde você
corre em uma infinita highway o trabalho
dele vai ter lá atrás quando a equipe
ainda nem sabe que vai ser um jogo até
lá no fim quando a gente está dizendo
esse carro tem que ter dois quilômetros
por hora mais rápido do ano por ora mais
jogar pra ajeitar para lançamento
dificuldade é o felipe me falou que
muito dessa mudança dos jogos punirem -
os jogadores têm a ver com a gente hoje
tem um monte de jogo para escolher em um
monte de lugar
eu posso jogar no computador no
videogame no celular
eu posso inclusive escolher não jogar e
ficar no instagram tentam o principal é
não respeitar o tempo de jogador
a gente não tem mais aquele contexto de
anos 80 e 90 que tinha um novo para
jogar pelo ano inteiro e até aquilo já
era hoje
se o jogador ficar muito frustrado e
perceber que ele perdeu o quinto hora de
o trabalho de jogo para ele vai procurar
o tempo tá muito papo a melhor o
conteúdo da internet e top
quando eu falei pra ele essa história de
a vida tem um seletor de dificuldade tem
um modo easy
ele chamou a atenção para um detalhe que
eu não tinha reparado
essa coisa de ter seletor considerada
ruim pelos games designers que jogo bem
projetado nem pergunta isso o jogador
imagina ele vai tomar a decisão mais
crucial do jogo dele
no primeiro minuto de jogo sem fazer a
minha verdade é que o jogo é essa
jogador bom ele vai se comprometer com
isso pra sempre pode pode ter errado a
mão nessa decisão ou então tem aquele
negócio tipo a qualquer hora do jogo ele
paulo e coloca no fato também fica
parecendo que o jogador roubou ontem por
um apanhando por japão e vão colocar no
papo não foi uma grande honra e portanto
o raio x o jogo de corrida que a
infinita highway não têm nível de
dificuldade
ele cuida dessa dificuldade de um jeito
inspirado em jogos da série super mario
o mario 64 era o seguinte tinha é 120
estrelas ou pegar ao longo do jogo que
dava para terminar o jogo pegando umas
50 60 destas só que pegando a 120 era o
seu objetivo final mas difícil mesmo é o
jogador mais loucão ea conseguir a gente
foi uma ideia parecida que as corridas
ela mãe da cimpor que pode jogar o iff o
modo fácil que é vai tirando o terceiro
quarto lugar vai dar pra avançado vai
abrir espaço países vai para abrir os
carros ocorrida em um ano normal médio
teria quero tirar o primeiro lugar
enquanto o ocorrido aí é um pouco mais
difícil e tem o difícil que é a um
jogador que quer tirar joel super troféu
que a gente chama em toda corrida em
primeiro lugar com todo o dinheiro
então lá e eu tenho uma coisa muito
legal quando estão fazendo cada episódio
do podcast que eu nunca sabe mesmo como
o episódio vai acabar eu vou descobrindo
isso enquanto eu escrevi o roteiro é
mentira isso não é nada legal essa
desesperador é tipo começar a escalar
uma montanha sem nem saber para que lado
fica o pico só acreditando que depois eu
subi até uma certa altura aí sim vai dar
pra ver o caminho até o topo
esse podcast aqui por exemplo se seria
ao vivo
quando me chamaram para fazer um
episódio ao vivo aqui no tribunal eu
aceitei
é claro que aí qual é o desafio para o
jogo contar uma história que seja legal
pra vocês aqui na platéia
todo mundo que foi o programa depois
certo só que aí eu fiz que nem todo
jogador de mario 64 de roger sanchez
eu escolhi que eu não só ia chegar no
fim que eu ia pegar todas as estrelinhas
é um super troféu antes de saber o que é
a falar de ter qualquer estrutura de
roteiro eu já decidi que eu ia usar
essas entrevistas sobre o videogame que
já tinha gravado com felipe e com
pessoal do pouco pincel eu também tinha
que começar com uma história minha que
eu sempre quis contar sobre o urso o
jogo online antigo aí eu tinha que fazer
uma profunda perguntas sobre a vida para
então chegar a uma conclusão enfim um
monte de moedinha espalhada pela pista e
pra aparecer com um videogame de verdade
eu tinha que fazer tudo isso que eu
falei com um relógio enorme e uma
contagem regressiva de 18 minutos bem na
minha frente só nível rádio é gente sem
nível pesadelo escolhi o nível mais
difícil do jogo sem ninguém ter me
colocado lá eu sei que a vida é mais
complicada do que o videogame
eu por exemplo sou da galera que
acredita que a gente só tem uma vida
nesse jogo ainda assim agora aqui depois
dessa jornada com vocês eu pude ver que
os jogos em sim pois pra ensinar sem
parar para entender isso não ia ter
conseguido chegar aqui na fase final as
palavras que eu sempre falo no fim de
todos os meus programas planos de
internet promete brasil por hoje é só
[Aplausos]
[Música]